foreign
that was yesterday uh this is today
um welcome to another honest trailer
commentaries Spenny is out on vacation
right now so you've got us and today we
are going to be talking about the honest
trailer that came out yesterday for Team
America World Police
um I am Danielle Radford uh as per
always I guess
um oh right here with Lon Harris how you
doing mom pretty good pretty good pretty
good doing pretty good not bad not not
bad um and so let's talk a little bit
about Team America work police a million
years later yeah well almost 20 yeah I
think it's 2004 so we're almost we're
almost 20 years later yeah like I the
South Park guys are are funny like Trey
Parker great writer they're funny guys I
enjoy their sense of humor there's a lot
of funny bits in this movie we have one
in the trailer that I think is probably
the best Joker he's like you may need to
take you take yourself out if you get
captured yeah and you think it's gonna
be like a cyanide pill thing and he just
gives him a hammer uh like there's lots
of good bits like that but the the
politics on this one have not have not
aged well I don't know yes it's hard to
watch this one in some ways it's um
going back it was definitely and we we
talk about this and we'll talk about it
when we get into the trailer but just
recognizing and being like Oh yeah
that's that that's that edgy midnight or
mid-auts comedy yeah like that's that's
that stuff I remember that now
um a lot of that and just the politics
of it too like I I think if this was if
the if the idea was just we're gonna do
a parody of like over-the-top Michael
Bay American action films but with
marionettes I think that's very funny
and I think they pull that off really
well and it was just that I think the
movie would Age great and we'd all still
love it to this day but they also decide
to add in this it's also going to be a
satire of the war on terror and the Iraq
War and like the Bush Administration of
the Bush Doctrine and as that goes it's
like real cringy and and tough to watch
now that we know yeah
master all of that foreign policy was
that final speech with the bunch of
words I can't say right YouTube promises
and anuses yes and the ones that go into
the ones and then the then the one hole
and you know that's different bodily
holes is a metaphor for uh global
conflict and yeah the policemen of the
world and the war on terror and
but again it's just going back it was it
was the the that's what jokes were then
sort of I remember like I remember when
I started doing stand-up like during
that odds period And like I have got
thankfully none of it on video but I
have I've said some regretfully bad
cringy stuff nothing like that but like
um thankfully none of the like ironic
racism or any of that stuff but
definitely some stuff where I'm like
Danielle what are you even saying like
that doesn't make any difference so it
just it really encapsulates like that
like this is a perfect time capsule yeah
it was a moment in comedy where we we
you know there was this idea that we
were sort of like well we're post racism
we're post homophobia like we we as a
people have gotten over all of that and
now we're able to look back at it and
and laugh and that was the prevailing
idea not true no but that was the
Prevail as the next couple of decades
would she tell us yeah so when you see
Clips like Sarah Silverman on her comedy
Center show and blackface from that era
or like the South Park guys using the
F-bomb for homosexuals yes movie over
and over again that was like why it was
okay according to yes the the culture
I'm making fun of people who think that
way but they're still saying it the old
like the old like Louis CK like it's not
it's not a racist joke it's a joke at
the expense of racist people who believe
race and yet I still get to say the word
and get the laugh from it so it's a way
to and and we all knew at the time that
everybody was having their cake and
eating at you it was always a little bit
of yeah Best of Both Worlds and this was
what like Dave Chappelle when he walked
off Chappelle Show like this was his
sort of the meat of his complaint and
and wait we don't have to get it all
that but it's like it's it's that issue
on top of I feel like Trey Parker and
Matt Stone legitimately were more
irritated by celebrities who were
anti-war than they were the idea of
blowing up Afghanistan and Iraq like
like they like Alec Baldwin and Rob
Reiner being anti-war in the in the sort
of you know like annoying self-important
condescending way in which they went
about being anti-war was more irritating
to these guys than the Bush
Administration which is why George Bush
Dick Cheney they don't get puppets they
don't get made fun of Janine garofalo's
puppet gets brutally murdered like yeah
it is a little bit of that like
um that Jurassic world where like the
nanny gets like the worst death even
though it's it's claimed now that she
told Trump yeah I think that actress
said she wanted him yeah she which is
like if that's that's dope I would do
the same thing
um be like yes please kill me as
gruesomely as possible but it does have
that feeling of like well damn why are
they catching so many Strays like yeah
exactly and so I think you know the move
like a lot of the comedy holds up better
I think than the POV yeah and I don't I
don't want to speak for spending here
but I know that he was also like well
maybe don't get your politics from a
puppet movie but we'll ask him when he's
back in but for now let's go ahead and
start watching uh the Team America World
Police honest trailer
yeah I love that
brilliant of the three of us he was
definitely the one who liked it
from the country that spread involuntary
freedom from Asia to Afghanistan
it becomes a film that takes a few punch
shots at the American Military but drops
an absolute nuke on the entertainment
industry I'm not from Hollywood I'm not
going to [__] your mouth and my time is
extremely valuable America F yeah actors
have you Matt Damon
Team America World Police
I I am curious as to how Matt Damon
feels about this because at that that
more than maybe anything else from this
movie I feel like that's what stuck is
people saying his name like that oh yeah
no that can't feel I mean I think that
you like take it on the chin as it were
oh man that was a bad because the chin
on the puppet um but I think that you do
kind of like take it on the chin but in
in
public and in private you're just like
[Applause]
who are some of the celebrities who get
puppets in Team America I feel like
people wouldn't remember I really didn't
remember most of them I feel like the
only one everybody remembers is Matthew
yeah and like maybe
um maybe I like Baldwin yeah but that
bone who's got like the most screen time
yeah Matt Damon's got the memorable bit
of just saying his own name in the again
in the voice that we you really wouldn't
wouldn't do anymore but in in 2004 we
were making fun of how people used to oh
we used to be so ableist and benighted
this is what passed for comedy but we
can still do the voice and get the
laughs for it
it's so funny all right let's keep going
when Trey Parker have cranked out 25
years of South Park but that's
overshadowed some of their most
important work the time they went to the
Oscars
[Music]
and the blackout drunk commentary track
for cannibal the Musical God I'm so
[__] up you guys
before Book of Mormon cemented their
status as comedy Legends revisit a
forgotten hit that's hilarious at times
now I have seen everything really have
you seen a man eat his own head
no so then you haven't seen everything
and dated in others
bricks oh no but just goes to remind you
they've been doing this forever their
dumb cartoon has outlived both of their
biggest villains Saddam would you let me
do my job please
do you think puppets are funny hope so
cause they're coming to the big screen
in a big way not with a charm and
cuteness of the Muppets but more about
Thunderbirds or Captain Scarlet Vibe
crash that helicopter no
Great Britain no we're even though the
production uh that was I saw a clip I
had never heard of Captain Scarlett yeah
me either I only knew Thunderbirds and
then uh oh like last week somebody
posted to social media to Twitter that
clip a run of Captain Scarlet Clips
which apparently was it was the same
Creator as Thunderbirds around the same
time but it was like super violent even
though it was a kids show the puppets
are really killing each other like
there's a clip there was a clip of like
a Creed like a car accident where you
could see the puppet getting crushed it
was unbelievable so I like it was like
an emergency like I wrote Kevin it was
like we have to put in one of these
captains Scarlet Clips this is Bonkers
and you can see like the puppy gets
blown away and then electrocuted and
like man that was entertainment back
then I remember these are for like
six-year-old like adults are watching
the marionette action shows those are
for children yeah definitely for kids
except for this one a little behind the
scenes for you guys that Captain Scarlet
was a late edition
insanely complex and difficult they move
the puppets bad on purpose for the sake
of Comedy
[Music]
laughs
you know what they're right this is way
funnier than trying
meet Team America they're like the cast
of Starship Troopers only slightly less
wooden there's Chris who tried to warn
us about cats before it was too late
rumpus cattle but cavity kept feeling up
my leg I tried to leave but Rubble
teaser held me down and I was raped by
Mr Mistoffelees Joe a big white slice of
All-American dumbass I'd love to show
her full moon night on the cornfields
Sarah the empathetic one
[Music]
and then be there
Gary and Lisa like that's right is the
filthiest thing to happen to a doll
since Ryan Gosling auditioned for Barbie
that
sex scene with the puppets is so long it
takes a little yeah it's really loud you
could tell like I I feel like there were
a few things that were the this is why
they made the movie that's one of them
yeah the throwing up scene is one of
them and then the like destroying the
entire city with the America song you
know like yeah I feel like they came up
with those bits and then yeah the rest
of the movie was like what can we put to
Strings we put some other stuff here but
first we got to make sure we have like
five good minutes of puppet yeah Pub
just like like passionate puppets but
also like in that it's it's not really
well pulled off like oh no no it does
look like just like two people smashing
their Barbies right like like I think
that because you can see they had this
very sophisticated setup where there are
all these like they could have made it
look right but that's not realistic but
right they're they're really leaning
into the fact that'd actually be really
disturbing I don't want to watch like
realistic puppet sex you like that
anomalisa stuff where like oh absolutely
they're really trying to make it look
more lifelike not disturbing yeah
keep going
Miss Gary an actor with exactly two
jokes one actors are dumb my acting
saved the entire world I'll never act
again you can't out at me boy don't even
try two puking is funny
I can't even watch
[Music]
I do love a joke that goes from like too
long anymore yeah sit back to being
funny
oh scratch that it's funny again no one
is safe from their withering satire
except for disaffected Libertarians like
Ben Trey are always right for not caring
about anything from the clueless
military blowing up the world
pause
well our third love
well we that's also your clue for next
week uh the the next film we're doing
also an action climax that's set at the
Loop and we will say no more
we've it's not da Vinci Code we did
DaVinci Code already which has a a big
set piece sequence
then this week Team America big they
blow up the Louvre the Nerf and then
again next week different movie
different climactic action sequence also
I believe it's underneath the loop I
don't know why I say that like nerve
the Nerf I think it's like a like
streaming services that have plus uh you
know there's there's that French one
Canal plus so in my head I always think
of like oh Paramount plus Paramount
Blues
keep going
[Applause]
damn I missed him so the activists who
are gay and bad for thinking that should
stop
to the foreign people who look and sound
different from us get it
it's a still round face if it's a puppet
yeah regardless for early 2000s Edge
there's still plenty of jokes that hit
hard if the terrorists take you prisoner
you'll probably want to take your own
life yeah you'd better have this and
just like all their other work the songs
are the best part everyone has AIDS
Freedom isn't free I'll just be
just
[Music]
so return to a tie most funny people
would beg us to forget in a comedy that
mocks the tropes of 80s action movies
yes they're ticking crack while having
all the tropes of mid odds comedy ironic
homophobia that is the way ironic racism
and also somehow ironic adult puppetry
Elma gave Helen all the pleasures a
woman could dream of
she had very large bosoms
nope sorry not puppets who kill it's
funny but Canadian we're focusing on
America right now let me give that
oatmeal some brown sugar
yeah hi sorry before we get to the story
yeah that was such a weird thing that
there was all of this like oh we're
gonna we know uh we're gonna take like
these childhood things like puppets and
make them all dirty that was also like a
huge thing uh you know there was that
show on Adult Swim Wonder shows in that
was basically like naughty Sesame Street
and like all of these that was a big
Trend then oh it was huge yeah like it's
like oh it's like you usually you think
of this character as for children but
women it was for our adults we made it
naughty what if they F like well when I
used to start like as a kid you'd come
to like the big city and there would be
like graffiti and like it was like
Mickey Mouse but he's on psychedel Alex
Bro like like what if Bugs Bunny was
smoking a joint man that's crazy it's
like that that level of Comedy yeah and
we did it a lot yeah I love I will say
uh that Arrested Development clip we cut
right before one of my all-time favorite
Arrested Development jokes where he's
you know because the dad is George Cedar
is strangling Franklin and so you've got
you know job is like yo that's my neck
but he's also like Dad that's my hand
yeah anyway it's funny dad that's my
hell yo man that's his hand it's the
same with Franklin
God that show was good Frank was amazing
everything with Franklin
all right and let's do starrings
Tall Tom Cruise would the guy in the
chair Joey Utah
empaths of Glory Chris Pine dude Nukem
The Hunt For Red Oak Timber
by crypto
stringsman the not so Secret Service
[Music]
I don't think that's allowed
well I can't steal a bit from your
cartoon show and put it in your movie
new bits new bits only we're not allowed
to say bring up my balls at a funny
carving voice again how dare you dare
you all right well thank you all so much
for joining us uh we're just gonna take
a quick pause right here just to be like
yo uh we're happy that you're here we're
happy that you're watching make sure you
subscribe to the channel for all the
videos uh every weekday you can hit that
like hit that Bell and then uh you can
be notified of every time we're doing
one of these uh silly little show is
live and so now I think we got some
outtakes so let's see what we got and
then after that we will open it up to q
a
starring wooden acting act hard American
duty Lisa Lawless basil ammunition
roller chair from husk Till Dawn she
sends eight post-traumatic cats disorder
ill communication John time no see 30
blog South Park bigger longer and strung
up
G.I Joe
[Music]
how did the interview cause an
international incident with North Korea
but not this
foreign
[Applause]
German
I don't know that's a good question yeah
he didn't hear about this one I don't
know I just didn't
yeah uh all right so let's get into some
questions here what do we got
um oh Evan J Price are asked why do you
think the edge the edgy puppet Trend
even happened to begin with it does seem
very random okay well cool we already
touched on that one
um oh Adam hope it's also just it's like
there's always something inherently
about puppets being dirty that's that's
funny like it's just because they're
they're so silly they're so childlike
they're they're innocent and so any like
that's always even before this yeah just
corrupting anything like meet the
peoples that Peter Jackson think but
even going back to like I think the
first puppet shows in like the medieval
puppet shows would have been dirty oh
they would have been filthy that's
always been part of the appeal I think
of Puppets yeah
um Adam Holbert what out of date comedy
didn't work for you on a first recent
viewing mine was Heather's take on
suicide and shootings I could see that
um oh right what like what clap like is
the question like what old comedy
doesn't
yeah I'm guessing it's like yeah like
what old comedy have you seen recently
like and maybe it's the first time you
saw it or I mean I think it's for me a
lot of stuff from this era even stuff
that I liked in this era does it like a
lot of it doesn't hold up because it
does a lot of it always feels like it's
it's a little for it's going for that
trying so hard to be edgy yeah and I
just it's it's it's more funny when
you're not trying so hard yeah I will
say well I wasn't I've seen it before
but it had been a minute but when we
went back and did the 500 Days of Summer
um I went back and I was like oh
I remember when people were like oh this
is like the cutest like sweetest little
comedy ever and I'm sitting there
watching it and I'm like this is like
just
real like it begins with the writer
actually calling by her actual name the
actual person summer is based on like a
name
I will also say uh
Caddyshack the bits that feature The
Comedians we all know and love your
Brian Doyle Murray's your your Bill
Murray's your Chevy Chase's their
sequences still hold up Rodney
Dangerfield there's a lot of great stuff
Ted Knight a lot of great stuff in that
movie with all those actors yeah but
that most of the movie is like the
caddies and that stuff does not hold up
that well at all like all the stuff you
remember from Caddyshack is from like 20
of them yeah yeah adult cast and
everything else with the caddies is
largely forgettable I will say that
um Pericles Dragon Balls uh says what
other movies could have benefited from
using puppets
oh you know what honestly now that we've
talked about what a fun movie this would
be if it was just like kind of not so
based on the war of Terror
I would love to see Independence Day
done with puppets oh that's a good one
that would be dope yeah I think I think
in the same way that this is a like
works best as a parody of like overblown
action like summer blockbuster action
movies I feel like something like using
puppets for like a very dramatic genre
like a legal thriller you know like
imagine like a pelican breed yeah
exactly imagine like a Grisham thriller
or something but it's all they're taking
it playing it totally straight but it's
all puppets like I think that that would
be a lot of fun that would be so much so
many slats yeah just like right like
like Pelican briefs I couldn't come up
with a better that's the perfect or I
always think I got time to kill but
right like one of those exactly oh yeah
I would watch the crap out of that Roman
J Israel Esquire no
I'd never seen
never seen us watched it the other day
because it's on like stars or one of
those it's really good have you seen it
it's really dead cells of me I know is
nominated for like an Oscar for it I
never saw it he's amazing
Denzel Washington
turns out it's Daniel Roy the guy who
did Nightcrawler okay that okay that
makes more sense
um what do we see here
Johnson could a team America sequel work
now or is the comedy too outdated
I think if you went in with a totally
different like we're gonna make fun of a
different genre like we're gonna do
things very different and you updated
the political commentary to be more 2023
sure like puppet parody thing I think
sure you could do it yeah I think any I
mean I mean I think if they did it today
you make fun of the red noted genre of
stuff throw in a little bit of superhero
mocking and I think that you've got it
you know yeah I think that could still
work
um what else we'll take a couple more of
these
um
James bunt dude you remember GI Joe the
Rise of Cobra also destroyed Paris
that's right yeah they're goo they use
those goo bombs on the Eiffel Tower goo
bombs that gee the first GI Joe movie
they're they're fighting like a super
weapon and it looks like Snot it's just
like goo green goo but it like eats away
at stuff remember so like they shoot it
at the Eiffel Tower did I put that in
the memory disintegrates the Eiffel
Tower and causes it to topple over but
it looks that was one of those first big
movies where it was just like the the
bad guy is just like goo like we're just
shooting like this weird radioactive is
that where we got the goo from I mean
can we give the grid can we give the goo
back
there's so many good movies we're gonna
I want to give the goo back um then in
Quantum 80 is just like 90 just all snap
just awesome
what if the goo is the higher movie
Arthur Mingo uh says which is worth
worse for Matt Damon this or being
bounced from the end of Jimmy Kimmel all
the time oh the Jimmy Kimmel bits [__] I
feel like he's in on that one yeah he's
definitely not in on us
because they've worked with so many of
the actors that like they murder in this
you know what I mean that's true I mean
at this point there is there is
establishment Hollywood as anyone else
I've been doing it from since the 90s
yeah wow God man I was in college when
South Park was new
Gray
[Laughter]
got that graybeard yeah um and then I
guess we'll wrap it up with this one
from Reynard City uh update Channel Team
America versus The Muppets who wins
I mean they're American icons yeah their
movies are so good but wait do you mean
like who wins the battle for our hearts
or do you mean like who wins in a fight
I even in a fight
oh no I think you said animal loose on
them Tina America has got nothing
they've got that guy who throws
explosives at everybody the dynamite
that's true yeah he's a muppet yeah that
guy the other guy who could throw fish
at them they've got Gonzo the great Gods
he's got cannons you can just throw
cannons at him uh attack them with
chicken will distract them with Joe oh
and then obviously um Miss Piggy's got
you know Pig Foo or whatever yeah yeah I
think I think yeah yeah all right so uh
we already gave you our clue for next
week and that is uh that I'm not gonna
do it again and again and again and
again we already gave you the clue so we
will see you all next week
I made that quick sorry
[Music]